oh dude I passed by a giant crab
yesterday
it was it was a king crab in a window oh
[__] this was in this was in
Newcastle it's a giant king crab in a
window New Castle
and all I could think was just running
up to it and striking through the glass
through its head with a sword that's
that's all that was on my mind yeah but
that would be a quick death
yeah you're right that's not good enough
no I was gonna strike the sword and just
get its left legs
I think throw them out in the street and
chase him do that right but then you pin
It to the Ground
you take the other half and you tie
those things to your like moped yeah
yeah right each one of the each one of
the deliveroo bikes yeah right boys let
it rip is that what is this old joke
um
oh that's just their uh ubereats okay
um I'm so I'm so English now man we
talked about fish and chips last time
yeah man we went out for dinner on
Thursday
[Laughter]
and I saw you know I was like I saw fish
tacos on the menu I was like that's
pretty much as close as you can get yeah
and if I get fries separate you know
pretty much
uh
so I got it and I'm like are these good
he's like oh yeah I didn't I just had
him for lunch this morning for today
I highly recommend them I'm like great
[__] yeah breaded please make sure these
[__] are fried
yeah and it just was not the same not
even bro
no
you're thinking about her
everything reminds me of her everything
yeah more UK Tings I just remembered
something I actually meant to say this
when I was in Birmingham the gritty is
worldwide
okay and and when I say that what I mean
is
um
I'm literally doing the goody right now
okay that statement is worldwide really
dude walking into a Tesco I'm standing
outside of Tesco
and it was like I don't know three women
they're they're walking around they're
like a bottle of vodka so they're at
least you know 12.
and
now they were you know I would imagine
they are like college or on the cusp of
okay and
they're in full English accents you know
Midlands English accent
and then they they break character and
in perfect American English I'm
literally doing a goodie right now
like they said to you
uh no they're saying it to each other
like joking around yeah wow and then I
was watching some because you know now
my phone my phone's been listening to me
so I get pushed like like Ireland
subreddits and you know UK tick tocks
and I was watching some video
and
yeah like the the people in the video
were were just somewhere you know not
America and same thing bro character
so I'm willingly doing a goody right now
really yeah I didn't even say it in a
British accent mostly doing the gritty
right now no no wow
oh mate I'm literally doing the gritty
right now
I don't know where that would be that
might no I don't know the news wherever
Liam was from yeah no that's that's Adam
oh yeah yeah you're right look up Adam
love Island birthplace
oh mate I'm literally doing the gritty
right now
that might be newcastle-ish dude the way
they say literally is so so unique
literally
from Newcastle yeah literally what the
[__] is Adam baller doing now oh it
turns out he's still hot
oh
he's blonde now
oh nice yeah scouse is the is the tough
one you know
I was [__] walking my dog and then
you just don't [__] take a [__] in
your front yeah
sorry on his uh
he just he just got lost yeah sorry I
lost in his chest he must have had the
Johnson and Johnson vaccine like a
thousand times because that one makes
you sexy right yeah yeah exactly that's
why they took it off the market by the
way guys we posted another Cody no I'll
do chaotic but I guess this comes out
next week so you would know probably you
would have seen it but yeah yeah well
let's reflect on our time with salt Hank
and Owen we can finally talk about it
together did we talk about our time with
Hank
no not really we I mean we we alluded to
it I think we joked we were laughing
about how we made him super racist
yeah so we we joke about that right like
one of the running bits is that like at
the beginning he said something about
Owen's eyes or something and then you
were like whoa don't talk about Asians
like that or something and I'm like
that's a little right and he was like
stressing so hard about it and then he's
you know his roommates with Connor so he
went home and then like later that day
or the next day or something he was like
dude Hank was a [__] mess when I got
home he was just sitting at the living
room table drinking a beer by himself I
want beer like I I need I had to like
I'm so stressed what just happened I was
like he was that [__] up about it and
he was like yeah man like you guys
messed him up
I was like we didn't meet it was all in
good fun like
oh dude it was too good saw Hank what a
trooper what a trooper man Noelle stops
between jokes like he's waiting for the
audience to laugh yes yes
I've been doing this my entire existence
the way Hank is panicking the whole time
trying to entertain the drunk children
next episode they have two teams uh Owen
and Noelle and Hank and Cody
um their cook-off would be nuts now why
did they spell Cody with a cake
so anyways people are loving it guys
yeah they're loving it so yeah give it a
watch if you haven't already now's a
good time should I Hank it was a good
time uh we got to do more of those
honestly we got to build a little
kitchen and just do them all the time
click the care the crab one yeah why
don't we close it out on fighting a crab
for a carrot
oh my God I don't think we can show that
why why not
I don't know isn't that
I don't know I don't know what the rules
is humane way to kill a crap oh just you
know the comments man why are comments
they're so obvious but they're so funny
does this hurt the crab
he made him a puzzle like God damn it
hilarious bro really said Perry this
[Laughter]
little bro got divided
that yo that that is the difference
between gen Z and us that's how they set
up their punch lines
they just put little bro in front of it
yeah exactly and it's funny like it
makes it funnier
[Music]
yo I'm about to hire this kid isn't he
good
you want to see the way he's walking in
the beginning
literally doing the goodie